c'est une histoire que nous vous avions
raconté ici même celle de ce bébé sans
existence légale néo domicile de ses
parents à Langeais l'enregistrement de
Timothée avec tes refusés par les tasses
civils 6 mois après la justice vient
enfin de reconnaître le lien entre
l'enfant et ses parents au terme d'une
longue procédure romain Delville
cette inscription sur le livret de
famille c'est un soulagement un retour à
la normale un apaisement pour la maman
de Timothée le bébé est né le 2 juillet
à domicile et sans assistance et c'est
une décision de justice qui tient lieu
d'acte de naissance un acte récupérer en
mairie de Langeais il y a deux jours ça
représente la fin de galère et ça
représente aussi la suite c'est à dire
que enfin on va pouvoir reprendre une
vie normale on va pour inscrire Timothée
à la CAF à la sécu enfin on va pouvoir
aller chez le médecin sans se poser la
question de comment est-ce qu'on fait
avec quelqu'un qui n'existe pas
on va pour aussi trouver une nounou je
vais pouvoir reprendre le travail
puisque depuis le 10 décembre j'ai dû
arrêter mon activité professionnelle
donc pas de rémunération non plus mais
que la procédure a été longue depuis
juillet pour la famille pour faire
valider qu'ils étaient bien les parents
de l'enfant né à la maison le couple
Carnoy a dû s'armer de Pat et de
multiples preuves j'ai un dossier de
suivi de grossesse j'ai cette chance là
d'avoir pu prouver ma grossesse à
travers ça et également j'ai dû demander
des attestations sur l'honneur de
personnes qui m'ont suivi j'ai dû
demander également à une sage-femme de
venir à domicile et de regarder par
exemple mon périnée enfin voilà on a pas
forcément envie d'étaler toute notre vie
comme ça
de la même manière on a été interrogé
par la gendarmerie donc vraiment on
donne naissance on a interrogé par la
gendarmerie c'est assez compliqué la vie
administrative normale reprend donc dans
la famille en 2023 6 mois après la
naissance de l'enfant sa maman est
rassurée s'il le souhaite Timothée
pourra passer son bac